so we start this NewsHour with the war
in Ukraine Russian media are reporting a
Ukrainian rocket attack has damaged the
dam that could lead to catastrophic
flooding Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski warned last month the
destruction of the Nova kokova Dam in a
russian-held territory would cause a
quote large-scale disaster for nearby
towns and cities the 30 meter High Dam
holds back 18 million cubic meters of
water from the nipro river which cuts
through eastern Ukraine
the dam is near the city of Hassan as
you can see on this map which Ukrainian
troops have been pushing towards for
weeks from the West in an effort to
recapture it from Russian forces
Downstream from the dam is
russian-controlled Crimea and IT
Supplies water to large parts of
Southern Ukraine let's bring in asset
big who's in kriviri in central Ukraine
asset as best you can make out what
actually happened at this Dam what can
you tell us
thank you
but it's very difficult to say what I
can tell you is that the Russians first
said that there were U.S supplied
missiles that hit that Dam the Russian
media said that they're very made the
point of making sure that everyone knew
that they were U.S supplied missiles now
we haven't heard anything from the
ukrainians but last month the Russians
also said Ukrainian missiles hit that
Dam now from the Ukrainian side there's
long been concern that Russia may try to
blow up that damn in fact last month on
the 21st of October Ukrainian President
Vladimir zlesky in his National address
warned that Russia was plotting to blow
that Dam up and claimed that Russians
had planted explosives as well as urging
Western powers to warn Russia not to
block that Dam because it would cause a
large-scale disaster now what we are
hearing is that her son is without
electro electric electricity and the
Russians are blaming an act of sabotage
on power lines uh that's what they're
claiming but this war has been full of
information and disinformation claim and
character claim and it's very difficult
to say because we don't have access to
the russian-controlled territory and the
ukrainians have been very strict on
media movements in her son as they get
ready to mount that offensive but what I
can tell you is that the ukrainians are
saying that the Ukrainian authorities
are saying that they are still 20 to 25
000 Russian soldiers on the West Bank on
the west side of that River and
russian-backed authorities in her son
have said that Ukraine is moving large
numbers of tanks and armored vehicles on
the on the horizon axis getting ready
for that offensive now the ukrainians
have been pushing forward on Hassan City
but that is very strategically and
militarily important to the Russians
it's the only Regional Capital that
they've captured since the start of the
war it's a gateway to Crimea but also
it's strategic for the Russians because
if the ukrainians get a hold of that
City and it is still a massive if it
will expose Russian troops elsewhere in
the country
I said update us on fighting in eastern
Ukraine what's going on there
well a lot of it seems to be centered
around the cities and towns of bakmut
and Soledad now the Russians have said
that the Russian troops have been
entering the city of Bahamut but the
ukrainians have just said that they are
still in control and that the Russia the
Ukrainian troops are unbreakable now
what we have heard is that there has
been intense shelling taking place that
there's been also trench fighting taking
place but the Russians have been trying
to try to capture the city of Bahamut
for months now I was there back in May
and there was lots of shelling taking
place then we were there just last week
and again the Russians had edged forward
but still didn't control the city of
Bahamut and again that is strategically
important for them it gives them access
to roads to other parts of Ukraine but
also the Russians want to be seen as
making advances they have had some
setbacks over the last few months with
the Ukrainian offensive and they've lost
some territory and the Russians are Keen
to show that they are still pushing
forward but as of yet what we're hearing
is both so it's claiming that they're
moving forward the Russians are saying
that they're entering the ukrainians are
saying that they're still in control
that's a big reporting from criviri
thank you very much